[Musique]
ce jeudi 22 juin ont été célébrés les
vingt ans dut air unités territoriales
routière au village de corail à saint
gilles du drc près de 300 agents
répartis sur quatre territoires
ils oeuvrent quotidiennement au service
des usagers de la route leur permettant
d'emprunter les 720 km de voirie
départementale
un anniversaire avec un bravo pour le
travail réalisé
720 km de routes départementales bien
entretenu mais aujourd'hui en berry avec
tout le travail fait par les agents qui
travaillent le bois de goyavier j'ai
voulu mettre en place aussi
l'embellissement rendent ce labo et bah
c'est plutôt bien réussi les gens sont
contents et puis merci parce que c'est
grâce à eux que ce travail il est il est
fait est que la population qu
réunionnaise ne peut se déplacer dans
une très très bonne condition
le département souhaité mettre en
lumière l'engagement des agents qui
composent les ut air ainsi que le
travail effectué divers animations ont
été proposées l'occasion pour les agents
de créer des liens de fraternité et de
solidarité est une fierté d'être
vice-président délégué au moment des
vingt ans iter 20 ans du tc 300 agents
qui s'impliquent tous les jours pour la
préservation de notre patrimoine routier
ce sont des agents motivés ce sont des
agents qui ont l'amour du travail bien
fait et je suis content d'être à leurs
côtés de partager ce moment avec eux ils
vont évoluer sur différents ateliers de
jeux d'animations pendant environ
deux heures l objectif étant de
capitaliser des points par équipes
au total il ya une trentaine des kits
composés d'environ 8 à 12 participants
qui fait tant qu'il y a près une
récompense pour les trois premières
équipes de 1997 a aujourd'hui nos routes
départementales se sont métamorphosés
une source de fierté pour gaillac
richmond 17 ans de carrière à lutter
ouest dans le temps c'était presque à
quoi il n'y avait pas de transport les
locaux abîmé toilettes presque
ça existe et pas franchement beaucoup
évolué sur tous les points a d'ailleurs
ma mère en matériel que ça véhicule les
outillages une journée festive pour
célébrer comme il se doit 20 ans de
travail au service des réunionnais
[Musique]